yeah I think one of the key pieces to
this whole thing is we need talk about
popping this credit bubble what
essentially happens here is the virus
starts to spread there is very serious
health concerns with that so whether it
is fear induced or actually that the
true health concerns what eventually
occurs is everyone has to stay inside
right and so you get a complete drop-off
and travel we're seeing across the
United States
these reservation apps are reporting 50%
or more in some cases drops in
restaurant visits the airline industry
is completely being decimated the rosing
as if millions of dollars Cruise Line's
hotels Airbnb etc and that slow trickle
across the economy is not just on the
consumer side it also happens on the
corporate side and so in a world where
everyone has been levering up with debt
you know for years now all of a sudden
they get a slowdown in revenue and EBIT
uh in in true cash flow they can't pay
the interest on that debt and you get
this kind of trickle effect across the
economy these mini blow ups of that debt
and I think that's really what you're
talking about here in terms of as that
domino effect starts we don't know how
big it is and how long it will last and
that's kind of the big concern if I
understand where you're coming from set
anga yeah you Fred you phrase it so well
yeah I've forgotten to come back around
to you know those of us who were who
were looking for the who realized we
were in an incredible debt bubble saw a
blow off top Lee I was tweeting out
yesterday looking at the updating of Fed
numbers in my own spreadsheet we had a
10% increase in a total amount of debt
outstanding in the just the last two
years in the United States that's a huge
acceleration and increase in debt we
certainly didn't grow GDP ten percent
over the last two years let's put it
that way so we were we just let him in a
drunken stupor and so we were those of
us who were looking at that kind of
those kind of statistics were sensitive
to what could pop the credit bubble and
then when the coronavirus came around
that that's you know that again Doug
Nolan was the first person that I saw
who called it back on back then none of
us were how how big of an issue this was
going to be but let me make this clear
the coronavirus is going to blow over
flues blow over
the 1918 flu lat it had three different
waves but it it only lasted fifteen
months and it killed several hundred
million people in the world but it
burned itself out in 15 months this too
shall pass the bigger issue is exactly
what you talk about which is that there
are a lot of leveraged businesses who
were not set up to have a to withstand a
shock like this and it turns out with
the debt bubble that we've had in the US
economy that the US economy is actually
really vulnerable to this
and as I was tweeting out back in
January in with after reading Doug's
post I'm worried about China's economy
as well because China has accumulated
debt it only took them 15 years to
accumulate the same amount of debt that
it took the United States more than 50
years to accumulate so there the
acceleration of debt in China has has
also been something that that you know a
lot of us have been watching as well and
so that you've got certainly the the
Western world the Americas and Europe
having been heavily leveraged going into
this coronavirus event but you also have
to have heavily leveraged as well so
what's interesting is that it really is
global